hey 42 here if you think making a
murderer was shocking you ain't seen
nothing yet it's estimated that every
year in Japan hundreds of people are
wrongfully convicted for crimes they
didn't commit
Japan is the land of extremes extreme
fashion extreme food extreme game shows
yeah so it only seems right that their
jurisdictional system is extreme - and
oh boy is it Japan boasts an
unbelievably high conviction rate of
ninety nine point eight percent compared
to America's eighty eight percent but
take this figure with a pinch of pickled
ginger because you won't believe the
lengths Japanese authorities will go to
to keep that figure so high
despite Japan being one of the safest
places on earth and the world's third
wealthiest country its justice system is
full of corruption and believe it or not
psychological torture and no they don't
force people to listen to j-pop for days
on end whilst force-feeding Scirocco to
them don't google suspects are routinely
subjected to inhumane questioning to
force them to confess to a crime that
they may or may not have committed just
so that the national conviction rate can
be kept at an impressively high level
you sit in Japan confessions are
believed to be the ultimate form of
evidence to prove a person is guilty
whereas other countries rely on more
tangible evidence to build a case around
it and then play a game of who has the
most expensive lawyer in court so the
jury can make a decision Japanese courts
have no jury a defendant's fate is
decided purely by a panel of judges it's
like a really depressing X Factor in
fact I'm surprised a Japanese haven't
made a game show out of it yet oh no
wait America beat you to that obviously
the verdict is almost always guilty
since police interrogators do everything
they can to forcefully extract a guilty
confession out two suspects before it
reaches court whether they committed the
crime or not Japanese police have been
known to use bizarre methods to extract
them
one woman was made to repeatedly shout
her confession out of the window another
man was forced to stomp on the names of
his loved ones by the interrogators
grabbing his ankles in some kind of
twisted game of do you feel guilty
enough yet in most countries such as the
UK and USA the police can only hold a
suspect for 24 hours after the arrest
but in Japan police can hold suspects up
to 23 days without any evidence during
this time the suspect is not allowed any
outside contact and they aren't even
allowed access to an attorney until
after the police have finished their
questioning Japanese culture places a
lot of pride on one's family members and
interrogators use this to their
advantage during a murder trial in 2013
one suspect said that the police
repeatedly told him that his mother
wanted him to confess or he would be
sent to bed without dessert but he
couldn't contact his mother to ask if
she really said this eventually he
confessed to the murder he later said he
was interrogated non-stop for five
consecutive days both day and night he
spent 29 years in jail for the murder
which it turned out he didn't commit
despite confessing to it he managed to
prove his innocence during a retrial
later in his life in 2007 in a small
town in western Japan 13 suspects were
accused of rigging an election via
vote-buying the suspects are all between
50 and 80 years old they were subject to
constant interrogations for months
leading up to the trial
six eventually buckled and signed
written confessions admitting they
bought votes with liquor and cash one
man died during the trial from stress
and another man in his wife tried to
kill themselves twice but the police
stopped them and arrested him for more
questioning come on now guys you've had
your fun
we can't force a confession out of you
if you're dead can't we all of the
surviving suspects were eventually found
guilty in court despite the police
having no evidence
kept from their confessions but later
they were all acquitted and the court
found that their confessions had been
entirely fabricated the judge actually
said they had quote-unquote made
confessions in despair whilst going
through marathon questioning in both
these cases or authorities received
absolutely no punishments for their
wrongful convictions the Japanese legal
system has been heavily criticized by
human rights organizations for years
such as by the United Nations Human
Rights Committee the head of Amnesty
International in Japan makoto tara naka
says the system is highly corrupt and
needs to be reformed he insists that
suspects are subjected to intense
psychological torture and he says Japan
is not a society where you have fair
trial things are improving though some
areas of Japan have recently introduced
a u.s. style jury system although maybe
this is not such a good idea after all
currently Japanese citizens do
everything they can to avoid court but
relaxing the system could open the doors
for more ridiculous or necessary cases
to go to court there is definitely an
issue with frivolous litigation in
America just like when DC based George
Roy Pearson sued his dry cleaners for 67
million dollars for losing a pair of his
pants yeah I'm serious
the court ruled in favor of the dry
cleaners faithfully and fined Pearson
for wasting the Court's time
Pearson totally lost his trousers over
the ruling thanks for watching there are
hidden oil wells all over Los Angeles
these secret oil wells are hidden right
in plain sight somewhere next to schools
and shopping malls he had simply gotten
drunk at a local pub and was walking
home past a palace at 7 a.m. when he
decided to go for a stroll through the
halls of possibly the world's most
famous residence